from the edge of the multiverse this is  the 4 player Lego dimensions battle  arena selected from an elite group of  men women ghosts dogs aliens  interdimensional beings and that guys  these four competitors will collide and  head-to-head dead-dead multiplayer  clashes once them Duke it out across 21  incredible arenas  and for thrilling game modes  there will be traps there will be giant  bombs there will be daggers falling from  the sky but they will do whatever it  takes to crush the competition and  become the Lego dimensions pedal arena  champion get ready to paddle and let the  games begin  Lego dimensions battle arenas and new  expansion packs are all compatible with  the original starter pack some toys in  consoles sold separately